do you listen to rogan's last podcast
with tristan harris and that other guy
about
he's the ethics officer was the chief
ethics engineer for google and he just
talks about how misinformation mal
information like we talk about guns and
all that and being ready for china's
military that ain't that ain't the
warfare you have to worry about the war
the chinese and the and the russians and
other foreign agents who are able to
create divisions in our country
based on false information radicalizing
our veterans for example who are really
good with violence trying to figure out
a way to do that
yeah not only that you're pushing people
further apart but the algorithm we know
that human beings
tend to
gravitate towards something negative so
if you see a negative article saying i'm
clicking on it you're going to click on
it the problem with that is it happens
automatically and it just keeps pushing
it well so the algorithm on youtube and
facebook does that automatically right
so it keeps pushing people farther and
farther apart but now china is starting
to see that so with china because they
can do [ __ ] china goes like this no but
china goes for their they go if you're a
kid
i think after 10 o'clock you can't be on
tick tock and oh by the way if you are
on tick tock after a certain amount of
time like 50 minutes or something you
can only watch science experiments and
other things really yeah they're not
[ __ ] around what they're they're
looking at um a tick tock and social
media for children as a health hazard
china is a health hazard which by the
way in a lot of ways it is no force and
so you know when you keep scrolling the
guy who invented the scroll thing it's
addictive
and they know it is yeah
now in china after you do five there's a
pause there's like a five second pause
and then and then and then you do it
five more and they so they have all
these built-in ingenious things and and
they were like we're not doing it well
so here's the big question youtube did
this censorship but here's the problem
the government could help you with this
but if you so if you're against the
government intervention you're still
being controlled by what corporations
who are making a fortune on the fact
that they can hijack your brain they can
they can jack your brain
and get tap into what it makes you makes
but even to elaborate on that but you
got to remember those those the the
power companies like facebook and
instagram who are owned by the same mark
zuckerberg um his politics are the thing
that are going to be the agenda on those
platforms right so even so even if
you're anti-government but you're still
on social media those social medias are
only allow access and show what agenda
they want to push so either way it's
still a government well so their their
um their rebuttal of that is actually
there's a very very vibrant right wing
community that uses social media i mean
they make a fortune doing that so so but
but it's really great but they don't own
the platform right and it's like youtube
instagram all that like well he also
said that he goes it's they may be left
but they also make a fortune off the
capitalist system they're also crushing
it and and you're right yeah they're
busy
and they have so much power
but the question is do you allow
government to come in the way they did
with network tv yeah network tv was
regulated by the government you couldn't
have swear words you couldn't have
nudity you could there was a stand
that's called standards and practices
when i was on mad tv the standards and
practices would when i had to do a thing
with a a tissue and i was always like
that i was i was doing i was doing blow
and they were like they they standards
in practice said it looks like he's
doing cocaine we can't have them on tv
so they were like just act like you have
a cold and i had to do it a certain way
so really yeah well we always should be
saying yeah yeah
i'm fine with that okay so but there are
a lot of people say oh you're getting in
the way of freedom of speech uh but when
it affects the health of the young and
it does yes
we know for a fact okay so now but now
are you super pro but there's a
right-wing group that says i'm not
letting the government do it okay but
guess what it's going to happen no
matter what right it's going to happen
no matter what right so those things
you're against going to happen no matter
what correct it's already happening
you're already don't act like we're not
being controlled you want to be
controlled by
zuckerberg and bezos and all and tim
cook and all those guys
they have a job to do they're going to
figure something out you can do that or
you have a standard that the government
sets you know i'm a i'm a pretty
i'm a libertarian kind of guy in a lot
of ways but listen we're getting to a
point where what are we going to do if
this [ __ ] is this it can't be the wild
west you got this is very interesting
how's it going like how so so are you
happy where we're at right now
everybody's happy exactly society's
happy how's suicide how's mental health
going yeah how's that going how's it
addiction how are you on your phone and
we know this isn't going to get better
so you want to just i know i'm i'm with
you freedom of choice all that i'm with
you but how's things going are we happy
with it right no
we did it
it's only get worse we know that
i think i think that there are a lot of
ideas that could really save us that way